this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development now let's meet today's
lecture today I have the pleasure of
introducing John L Warren
John is the vice president of strategic
business solutions for IPS learning he's
also the director of the IPS Center for
extra execution he's a key faculty
member for the Stanford advanced project
management program and has co-developed
of numerous courses the strategic
project management office projects to
enterprise financial mastery of projects
and executing complex programs he's a
30-year veteran a program and project
management and has expertise in overall
consulting product design strategic
planning and strategic team facilitation
he's designed and facilitated strategic
planning and strategy mapping at the
Library of Congress designed a complex
IT integration workshop for Barclays
bank helped Hewlett Packard established
and supported global multifunctional
program management office and his
current clients include HP IBM Marvell
semiconductor Santa Clara County Kaiser
Permanente Medtronic and top 100 500
polish innovators program well further
delay I'd like to introduce John Warren
thanks a lot Robert and hello everybody
out there I wish I could see you in
person so we're going to see you
virtually we're here from the beautiful
Stanford campus and looking forward to
share with you some thoughts that have
really come out of looking at the world
that all of you play in if you will and
work in and to help us out I wanted to
have a sense if you'll vote really
quickly about your exposure to our
program because I'm going talk about
some things that I would emphasize
differently so if you've not taken any
courses in the Stanford advance project
management if you'll click on that first
button the blue button would be you
start at least one course yellow would
be you've completed one or more courses
and if you're actually a graduate and
I'm certified have a Stanford
certificate let us know there so let's
take just a few minutes and if everybody
would give us a quick quick quick looks
like we have a lot of newbies
welcome to all of you we'll take a few
more minutes here watching that come out
hello to you graduates some people have
been in classes we're glad to have you
there but all of your new folks are
really glad to have you there so I want
to ask Robert to close that out so we
can get going here and we appreciate you
really being here if you think about the
this program it's really a mix of what
do you do in the real world if you will
on Monday morning and what do you and
combine that with the excellent theory
and research and experience from our
professors here at Stanford and other
schools and essentially in Silicon
Valley and what I've noticed over the
the last year or so and in working with
professors as well as working in these
large corporations that we serve through
IPS learning is that there's a lot of I
don't know bios discussion about
innovation and just this morning I did a
quick search on both Google and Bing and
there's somewhere between 320 and 420
million hits when you type in innovation
and so innovation is one of these things
that that we're hearing a lot about and
so what we want to do is set a context
here talk a little bit about how we
might think about innovation because
it's a word that's used in lots of ways
and most powerfully I want to make the
hook between innovation and what we
would call project-based work and I'll
talk a little bit more about that later
and then seven or eight things here then
what are the implications if you're
leading project-based work basically so
what what does this mean I think it has
some really really powerful implications
we want to make sure that we hit those
and then we'll take some time for
questions and comments and wrap up so
we'll have everybody on the way in about
an hour so I love this quote you know
one more time how do you innovate and so
I want you to be thinking about that I'm
on set the stage here with a little bit
of discussion from a fairly famous guy
in the business world Peter Drucker and
I want you to think about what does that
mean to innovate think about in your own
company the companies you work for
engagements you're involved in
what does innovation mean so that when I
sort of talk about this you've got some
ideas in your head again there's not a
right idea so let's look a little bit
the context some of you may have been
exposed to Peter Drucker if you've been
in Business School recently Peter
Drucker he's no longer alive I think he
died several years ago but he lived I
guess to 95 or 96 and the seminal
thinker in business and management and
even today his writings resonate just
across the space so I want to share with
you and set some context here let's go
all the way back and think about what is
a business and why is a company in in
business and if it's some of you with
nonprofits or not-for-profits you can
think about that your same thing you
have a purpose not to create customers
of people that you serve and so drunk
felt like that's that's why we were in
business and so then basically what the
business is revolves around what is it
you're trying to satisfy that that that
customer wants or needs and that
ultimately becomes a product or service
so if you think about that that's what
the business is in create a customer and
provide a service or a product that they
need now you say well how do we pull
this off and this is where I think the
connection becomes very very powerful
business really has two functions from
Drucker's perspective I'm doing
marketing innovation and he talks about
this quite a bit and here's the thing I
want you to remember think about this
marketing is all about how do I get the
cuff how does the customer know that I
have a product how does how do I get a
customer in the fold so in his world
market is very broad that's like the
funnel that gathers in the people that
you're going to satisfy their needs and
wants innovation is the park well what
am I going to give them what's the
services what are the products that I'm
going to give them that comes through
innovation and basically he felt like
you know that was the two main aspects
of business marketing and innovation and
this is what everything else became a
cost and so you wanted to focus on that
now where does that lead us well you
want to be able to not only create those
customers but maintain the
and so he felt like your success in
business really was tied to what extent
that you could develop innovative
products and services and for you to
stay in business grow evolve that
business you had to really out think and
help produce your competitors and you
basically do that through innovation and
that innovation is is really pretty
important and if you look there on this
slide but all companies have to really
try to figure out how do I better
satisfy the needs and wants of my
customers and they can be current
customers or future customers here's
what I want you remember what's in that
black oval all of that requires
innovation and that's our focus here so
keep in the context the purpose of a
business create satisfied customers that
requires marketing innovation our
particular focus is going to be on the
innovation part of that marketing brings
people into the fold if you will they
find out about you through marketing
innovation is how you actually give them
what they want or what you are providing
for them so now let's take a look at
this innovation as I mentioned this is
one of those words that is used just
it's sometimes I want to say let's have
a new word yeah that's too much thick
but I really like this very simple but
profound definition from Scott Anthony
he has a recent looked a little black
book of innovation very short and sweet
works with Clayton Christensen and some
of the people there at Harvard in the
innovation and disruptive innovation
area
he thinks of innovation is basically
something different that has impact now
I want you to keep that in mind as we go
through here I'm going to talk a little
bit about innovation some types of
innovation and then we're going to say
well what does that have to do with what
we would call project-based work that's
sort of the context of where we're going
so obviously there are innovations of
all types if you say something different
with an impact and I really like there's
lots of different frameworks and models
for how you would think about this this
particular one of thinking about these
categories of innovation so I'm going to
be very incremental so I'm a little bit
more significant and some
transformational so let's talk a little
bit about these and I'll share with you
sort of a really
a summary slide just a reminder to you
as Robert mentioned you can also select
and save these as a PDF so you'll have a
copy of these if you want so first let's
look at this first category of working
the core this would be basically where
you're making an incremental change in
your business it could be extension of
existing product so you have Oreos in a
bag that has five Oreos in it and call
it the hundred calorie bag instead of a
bag that has 500 calories in it things
like that or you may make an extension
of an existing service that goes into a
new area and basically using what's
already there but you are pushing into a
new area maybe new versions it may be
line extensions things like that that's
probably the simplest area of innovation
and I want you to keep in mind
innovation is difference with an impact
sometimes that impact is very small it's
still an innovation the important thing
here to keep in your mind it's
difference it's not just that bright
shiny new platform a new smartphone or a
new piece of software there are a lot of
other innovations that can come along
here now the adjacent categories
basically sort of working in the
business you're working on the business
I like to think of that if you're you
like math you're basically changing the
slope of the curve and you may do that
by using a mix of core activities and
some maybe some new ones you leverage
what you do you may use this to go into
a new market space but the key thing
around working on the business is you're
using existing capabilities so that you
can have new applications users things
like that now you can see there are some
of the examples under that that they
might be it may be a new s AP module it
could be a product that really goes into
a different platform
I mentioned gluten-free bread just as a
personal note my wife has cannot eat
gluten and and we've watched how this
whole gluten-free has evolved and a
great harvest bread company out of
Montana in the u.s. recently started
doing gluten-free bread on certain days
that is not a that is a definite
innovation for them but it was an
adjacent there
still using their existing assets but
they're going into a very different
marketplace things like that that's what
we invited Jason and then finally
transformational remember we're talking
about core sort of your basic type of
innovation using what you have then
you're looking at adjacent where you're
taking what you have maybe add in some
new things to it going into new markets
and then this transformational is really
changing your whole business model this
is the one I think a lot of times when
people think innovation this is what
they think about and I want to disabuse
us of that and remember that innovation
can occur in a whole continuum this
turns out I think to be very important
this could be where you have new
businesses new products radically new
products new services all of us look at
the technology we're using right now
basically this did not exist in this
form ten years ago you may satisfy
customer needs that are either new core
customers did not know they had they
literally create a new market typically
you're going to be using assets and by
that we mean people resources
technologies that you did not use before
you may build on some old and existing
but it's going to be a lot of new you
can see they're just some examples of
transformational categories I've done
some work with the US Library of
Congress and the whole book publishing
business if you think about it is
radically different now major major
innovations and business models and no
one's really quite sure how that's going
to sort out how we're going to view
videos and movies and TV channels
another example radically different now
just added one little note here because
sometimes the business model innovation
that's not a focus here but I wanted to
provide this because you have a copy of
the slides some information just to give
you an idea of what we mean by that is
is if you think about business model
innovation you think about either what
how you link things together you're
putting things together new combinations
or who does what you may be changing
that a really good example you think
about in book publishing as an example
used - that was done by somebody like a
Random House I went I ordered the book I
went to the book store and got that now
look what's happened
the I can go into an independent
bookstore in a small town in New
Hampshire they have a machine that
basically does print on demand and in
four to five minutes I can have a
hardbound book that was ordinarily not
available to me delivered in that
bookstore in that small town and that is
a radically different way of my
receiving the books that would be
considered a business model innovation
and you can look at your own companies
all of you represent and come from a
variety of companies same kind of things
so those are very transformational kind
of innovations if you're interested in
that I'd suggest very strong as a great
book called business model generation
I've got the website there for you and
Alex Osterwalder who was one of the key
authors in that spoken here at Stanford
and it's a great presentation he gave
for about an hour on business model
innovation so I would strongly suggest
if you're interested in that now what
does all this mean well here's a nice
great graphic way of looking at it and
we talked about core and adjacent in
transformation and nygean
tuft in this article out of Harvard just
a few months ago really summarized this
and so I just want you to keep this in
mind I'm gonna sort of summarize what's
on this chart and they were getting
ready to say well what does that have to
do with what I do and the project
you know based work that we do if you
look across the x-axis you'll know sort
of notice there is how to win and
basically difference between core
adjacent and transformational and here's
the thing that I want you to keep in
mind it's still innovation even if
you're using existing products or
existing assets that's still innovation
just because it's not the new platform
or it's not a product that no one's ever
seen before like a tablet or a
smartphone doesn't mean it's not
innovative so you want to keep in mind
as a continuum here and our focus is
related to right wherever you are on
that continuum to do very well now what
we see on the y-axis gives you some
examples that we this is in effect I
think a summary of the slides before is
that the focus is going to be quite
different if you're in the core adjacent
or transformational and what I want you
to keep in mind as we look at this is
that there's not a right place to be
in that space there there are lots of
places sometimes you may have work
that's in the core sometimes adjacent
and you may be lucky enough to be
working transformational a couple of
weeks ago I was at a large medical
device company and we got to have a tour
of their facility and they're working on
some new things in the diabetic arena
and one of the things they're working on
is a artificial pancreas this is sort of
like the holy grail of any of you
familiar with diabetes especially type 1
and that's going to be a
transformational product but it's still
very much in the R&D stage there's a lot
of things that we worked out so that's
transformational somebody back in the
core may be working on a better way of
working in a in their business they have
small pumps that you can wear on you
that for insulin and they're coming up
with a better design of that that's not
as big and all that's not a
transformational thing but that's a very
important innovation now let's see what
is that connect with us I'll put up here
probably a phrase you maybe not for me
with project-based work and really I
want to use that term too so I don't
have to keep saying projects and
portfolios and programs so we use PDW
our project based work to really include
projects programs people may call them
engagements initiatives anything like
that and the associated portfolios us
with them and you can think about that
as a placeholder so just keep that in
mind whenever you see PDW now what we
mean by the landscape of innovation to
innovate organization basically has to
be able to execute its strategy through
project-based work if you remember
anything from this talk is you cannot
innovate without project-based work our
challenge you look at any innovation and
say how did that come about it was
through project-based work you had to
create the idea develop it design it
figure out how to manufacture it go live
with it
all of that is project-based work if
there is no innovation then companies
perish remember when all the way back to
Drucker you have to do be very good at
both marketing and innovation
and frankly you know we're not always
thinking of that way now project-based
work remember all this project stuff
that we all lead is in the larger
ecosystem of the organization and this
is really where we make our connection
back to our Stanford program I'm so glad
we have many of you that this is your
first exposure to that and we spend a
lot of time in that program and looking
at a strategic execution framework and I
want you to we're going to talk about
that in just a minute but before I get
to that I want you to keep this
following in mind if you look at all the
money that's spit in your organization
there's two pies imagine you have a red
bucket in the green bucket and all that
money is either spent on running the
engine run in the bank run in the
company whatever you want to call it as
in operations or it's spent on project
based work it's in one of those two
project-based work is where we come up
with products processes services depend
on the kind of business you're in they
may be we're existing something that's
existing so we're enhancing that or
improving it maybe we're coming up with
something new
remember this goes back to our little
diagram of looking at core adjacent and
transformational types of innovation all
that comes down in this project-based
work space that is where the innovation
occurs and to actually execute your
strategy requires both operations and
project-based work now where does this a
couple with our Stanford program over
the years we have developed and involved
a framework we call it the strategic
execution framework you see a picture of
it there and I like to think of this as
a way that it helps organizations
execute their strategy through
project-based work and I want you to
keep in mind executing your strategy
through project-based work is how you
innovate you cannot innovate without
executing project-based work it's
impossible to do that let me just give
you since we have some new folks here
let me just take a few minutes and tell
you about this particular
chart if you want more information
please let us know we have further
information on this and we cover this
quite a bit in some of the courses
Robert will mention to you a little bit
later but basically the idea is to step
back and look at a high level what do we
mean when we're thinking about the
company itself and you'll see them up at
the top ideation we talk about purpose
identity and long range intention of who
you are as a company this turns out to
be really important you're going to see
why just a little bit so I call that
sort of the who and who you are then
over in the sort of blueish on the Left
you'll see what we call a nature domains
the term we use and that's a combination
of looking at the culture and structure
or the context what's the world that you
play in if you're an old company this is
awesome quite set if you're a new
company you're still evolving what your
culture and structure is going to be but
they're very important over on the other
side the yellow sort of the vision our
goal how do we know we're getting
towards that goal sometimes it's fairly
amorphous in the new space we're in a
transformational type area it's going to
be very if we're in a more core we'll
know exactly what that is and notice
what happens all of this comes crashing
together and merging together when we
get to strategy so we have to understand
the purpose the ad8 ideation of the
organization the culture and structure
where we're going to take that
organization in terms of goals and how
we pull that off is really what strategy
is about the portfolio aspect of that is
that no organization has unlimited money
even large companies that have lots of
cash cannot spend that money without
lots of decisions so portfolio decisions
basically here's the strategy and here's
what we need to do but we don't have all
the resources so we're going to use the
portfolio process to make that decision
that then goes into programs and
projects or what we would call project
based work and I want to emphasize
that's where innovation occurs
innovation requires project-based work
once it is done if you will it is
transitioned into operations and that
you're either so in that service or
selling that product or you're selling a
whole new set of products and services
the so that's the SEF and if you look
right over on the left you'll see some
that says external environment is a very
light gray
so my slots they're barely visible it
says external environment and all we're
reflecting is all of this thinking takes
place inside a very dynamic environment
it may be a regulated environment may be
a very competitive environment things
like that so that's a little bit of
background on that for those of you that
are new to that now let's let's think
about this just a minute what does all
this mean what are the implications of
this for those of us that lead project
based work and what can we do to take
this type of thinking and support
innovation so let me just summarize
where we're at here
we looked at what Drucker thought of is
in business business wants to create
customers and it does that primarily
through marketing and innovation
marketing brings people in the door it
also lets people know what you did you
exist innovation is how you build what
you're going to give them how do you
satisfy that need
through a process through a product or
service you do that through innovation
and then we talked about that there's a
a continuum of innovation there's things
where we work in sort of in the business
that's sort of a core type of innovation
it is a change remember scott Anthony's
definition change with an impact or
difference with an impact that's what
innovation is sometimes it's a big
impact sometimes it's a little one any
of you that fly on a plane a kiosk think
about that as an innovation ok that may
not be the same as an a380 double-decker
from Airbus but it is an innovation and
I was a changing at an impact so keep in
mind there's a whole range of these from
core to adjacent to transformational and
then we want to think about that in the
strategic execution framework that we
need to take in account the culture and
the structure of the organization and
frankly those really are going to be
critical in thinking about how we can
let project-based work support
innovation so that 8 items here I want
to talk a little bit about each of those
and then we'll get close to where we can
have some we'll have some discussion
about classes and then we'll have Q&A so
if we think about if you have any
questions or comments or something you
want to feed it in to us we have a
rather large number on here so we'll try
to get as many of those
as we can so let's see let's look at
these implications the fact that
innovation occurs through project-based
work first I think it's really important
that you the teams you lead the
executives that you work with your peers
really understand that project-based
work is how you do innovation if you
went and did a poll in your organization
right now most people would not make
this connection that's really where this
thinking has come from it's like Hello
wake up you know what's going on here
and somebody in the room you're laughing
about you know sorry we're in California
so you get the message it's like Hello
and that's what basically are we missing
here so basically I understand what are
the innovative elements that the
project-based work is producing and this
the second little bullet there is that
one of the innovative elements of
actually designing and running the work
itself they're innovative elements and
how you run the whole Lean Startup
initiative and I mishit abut people
thinking about that how we are thinking
about agile and all those are innovative
ways of running project based work and
so that is innovation so that's almost
like I'd call that a meta innovation
we're innovated how we innovate any time
we find better ways of leading managing
and planning project-based work we're
going to improve how the organization
innovates and I just want to basically
what our Stanford program is about is
helping you find and and new better ways
of doing that
second engage the team I think everybody
on your team whether it's 510 or 500
needs to understand this frankly if I
hear one more time somebody says I'm
just a project manager I'm just a
program manager I want to take the
bottleneck and shake them into wait a
minute how does your company innovate
you're not just a project manager or a
program energy you are the basis to
innovation in your company and that's
something your team really needs to
understand it will help you get through
those tough times and when you get beat
up on budget and all the other things
that happen in the
right now remember that and you need to
really really be you know forceful about
this they need to then understand that
even though it looks like a mundane
adjustment maybe you're improving a
process for how you manage new orders or
something like that and it seems like
just a grunt and grind kind of work they
need to understand that is innovation
for your company
and let them know they're on the
innovation team innovation in something
happens over in the innovation
department it happens with everybody so
we really want to think about that in a
very different way share with your
stakeholders people use different terms
for this and your company customers and
things like that I'll just make sure
that refrain in this of the
project-based work that you lead for the
you support is that the sponsors and
that may include you as well as
executives you report to understand that
they don't they don't get it
trust me I say this all the time
laterally would be the people in your
team the other people like yourselves
are leading project-based work and of
course we just talked about making sure
the people on the team understand that
so they really understand that
project-based work is that the core of
innovating in your company and then
finally think about there may be other
stakeholders some of our people that in
the Stanford program work in highly
regulated industries they may be
utilities they may be in parts of the
financial business they made financial
services they may be in medical services
things like that and it's really
important I think that your customers
and your stakeholders in those kind of
spaces really understand importance and
why you're innovating and how you're
innovating and make them really
appreciate that the internal
stakeholders are going to maybe people
that don't really appreciate some of the
work that your team's may be doing or
understand it and I think so if you look
at your communication plans for project
based work make sure you're hitting
people that really need to get this
project-based work connection now
customers we talk with mr. Drucker right
at the beginning about the power of
creating and satisfying those customers
and I think it's really important that
they need to understand how the
innovation that you're doing through
project-based work actually helps them
and if you're doing this well they want
to work with you because you're
everybody is innovative but you want to
be you're innovated in things that's
going to serve them better you're
constantly looking for ways to improve
how things are done and then the last
little bullet is basically the I think
it's important that under customers need
to understand that that a well-run
project-based work is it is basically
their interest I'm always thinking about
you talking to a customer it's in their
interest you know how to run your
business and you're really firm about
that and you they recognize that you are
innovating on their behalf so I think
that's probably the main thing takeaway
there I've alluded this a little bit but
I want to reinforce that when you think
about better ways of planning
project-based work that is innovation we
should always be looking about that I I
can't say enough put a double star about
the criticality of planning on an
ongoing basis this is not classic
planning again but you're always looking
what can I do better and how can we use
that planning to steep or immerse
yourself in your team in the
project-based work remembering that that
project-based work is how your company
innovates so your team needs to be
really steeped in it look at this at a
very holistic kind of systems approach
next little board there is basically
fine well better ways of managing and
leading so the first bullets about
planning think about how you can be more
innovative and how you actually plan
project-based work second bullet is and
okay how what about actually managing
and leading that project-based work what
have we not tried that can make a
difference and I know this is hard trust
me I'm in there with you and seeing the
challenges a day to day the urgent's
driving that out as always crises and
things are having to deal with but take
that time plan that time that you can
step back and help your team say what
can we do better and how to do things
that can really make a difference
hey don't copy they see what are other
people doing learning I mean this is
like best practices from a lot many
years ago that we still want to do when
we think about project based work is
innovation you want to learn from others
and then just a couple of more of these
and we're going to be ready for some
getting close to our questions I like
this idea of an innovation awareness
culture and there's lots of different
ways of thinking about this but
basically you want to reinforce the
project-based work drives innovation and
if everybody in the company is aware of
this innovation is not something done
over in the box in a corner just by
people with five PhDs it's done by
everybody with a particular mindset
anybody that's working on a
project-based work or project team
basically is working on innovation and
I'd ask you to think about that if you
say well sure about that then why are
you doing it if it's not innovating if
it's not difference with an impact you
need to ask yourself why are we doing
this is it making us a better company is
it providing a service or product that
is needed by our customers look for ways
you can create tools and things of
reinforcing that innovativeness and I
think that's what the mindset would
really bring as you run this type of
work there's nothing like teaching
others that's one of the best ways to
learn and so I think sharing these
thoughts both with your team have your
team then share with their teams you
have team leads how are your structured
in your project-based work teach others
about that reinforce this learn from
them and see what can you do in that
kind of thing and then finally change
this heck this is just eight eight ideas
it could be twenty more they could be
others so constantly be looking and
saying what can we do since
project-based work is the driver for
innovation we need to always be looking
at how can we do this better so that we
can basically better innovate as a
company now one of our most dynamic
professors is Bob Sutton if you get a
chance to come on campus you will see
Bob in some of our courses here and he
gave a talk last year on fast innovation
and I just wanted to sort of summarize
that up with it's really interesting
some of the keys about
that that he was thinking up as he was
sharing with that and he had Kevin Bain
who's one of these graphical taters grab
this this is a really interesting if
you're interested in that you can go to
that website and get a copy of it but
Bob was kidding about some of the key
things about fast innovation and all of
those actually dovetail with what we're
talking about in project-based work is
how innovation gets done now a quick
summary here and then Roberts going to
tell us a little bit about some of the
classes we have coming up here that are
relevant to this while we are organizing
your Q&A so if you have any QA now's a
good time to send them in we're trying
to organize and get these things all
done so questions answers things like
that we may not get to all of them don't
panic
we'll get them organized so you can see
them now a couple of things this is a
summary slide that's why such big ideas
create customers you do that through
marketing and innovation innovation
requires project-based work you may not
call it that that's what it is though
innovation occurs unless you have
project-based work that's why we want to
execute that project-based work well
because it will lead to more impactful
and dynamic innovations we have to do
both operations and project-based work
to pull off pull this off I mean you
think about strategy execution we got to
do both of those and in all of this I
would say project-based works are
bedrock for effective execution of
strategy and it drives the result in
innovation that's why we think that's so
important so let me hand this over to
Robert and I'll be back with you with
Q&A so send in your QAS great great
thank you John at this time again we
encourage you the audience to submit
your questions about today's
presentation our presenter will answer
your questions in a couple of minutes as
we gather questions I'd like to briefly
share some information about the
Stanford event project management
certificate in 1999 Stanford professor
ray Lovett
partnered with Stanford center for
professional development and IPS
learning to create this award winner
program focused on strategy execution
and management of project based work in
this program participants learn how to
strategically execute projects programs
and portfolios implement strategies
through effective management of
resources manage change in a
multi-dimensional environment and
improve productivity and profitability
certificate courses are offered in three
way at Stanford online and at work the
online videos are streaming so that you
don't need to download them and at work
can be brought into your workplace and
courses taught right there on site to
earn the designation on Stanford Center
certified project manager participants
must complete three required courses and
three elective courses on a variety of
topics to create a customized curriculum
as you can see we have converted
strategy into action executing complex
programs and leadership for strategic
execution as well as the electives you
can see here we also offer courses on
campus this coming September will offer
six courses if you enroll today you can
save on tuition and feel free to reach
out to any of our customer service
representatives online and they'll be
happy to help you so let's take a quick
poll before we move on what is your
interest in the S APM certificate
program please answer now I am
interested in attending a September
on-campus course I'm interested in
bringing the S APM program to my company
I am interested in taking online courses
you just like more information on the
program just to kind of figure out if
it's right for you or you're currently
enrolled in the SAF courses or program
graduate again please answer by clicking
the colored box that corresponds to your
answered i'll close the polls in a few
seconds
great thank you for your feedback the
polls are now closed so let's get to the
question and answers I'm going to open
it back up to John John what's our first
question okay hey guess what I forgot to
ever be a new button and how you can
hear me this is John ok pol oh geez here
I was chattering away without hitting
the button somebody asked about
differential differentiating between
projects and programs we lump all those
together and for project-based work they
are different they're managed different
they're led differently but that's not
really I don't think I need to say
anything else about that there's a lot
of information about that if the company
culture does not recognize that you do
project-based work how do you introduce
that into the culture in order to
innovate successful well a couple of
things first thanks for asking about
culture and and our way of thinking
about this culture is absolutely
critical if you culture and
understanding that is just is paramount
first I not knowing the setting here
project-based work I cannot think of any
company that doesn't do that they just
may not call it that so don't get hung
up but it's PBW you have to do that if
you're building a new product if you're
building a new service if you're
enhancing it that's a project it's
something you spend money on you do a
short amount of time and then you you
know put that into operations so I
probably need to know a little bit more
but I think the important thing to
understand is that you are doing project
based work find out what you call it and
then make that connection and ask how do
we innovate here what is innovation for
our company is it a new product as a new
service how do we pull that off you have
to do a project I don't know either you
do it you pay somebody else to do it
that's what that is that's a quick
answer on that one are there any
interesting tools on the market that
support this for small teams remember
PBW we're not creating something new
here we're using this as a vehicle for
thinking about the whole project
landscape and we just using pvw as a
placeholder for that so we don't have to
keep repeating them over and over there
are lots of tools for small teams I
would say whoever asked
send me an email I continue s'mores a
lot of web-based tools like Basecamp and
all I'm not endorsing any of those that
are great for small teams one of the
most interesting tools I've seen is like
a the one-page project manager as a book
free websites all done in Excel it's
great for small teams and small project
is not good for things that are really
big and complex really really useful
there what are the key skills for
project based work does the professional
need project management knowledge only
or the technical know-how as well that's
a classic challenge especially in
technology spaces can I know just
project management but I also need
technical from my experience you need to
have both here's the challenge a lot of
technical people become leaders of
project based work they become a project
manager a program manager they don't
know anything about that they got that
because they're really good in the
technology so they need to have
additional education or experiences to
learn what is it I need to know to
actually do this project-based work I
would say that the skills with
project-based work of the classic ones
that you want to see not just
technically the interpersonal and our
focus really I think in the Stanford
program is understanding that every
we're not teaching you how to write code
or teaching you how to design a new
product that's not our purpose but what
we are doing is helping you understand
what are those skill sets involved with
leading people with leading teams with
negotiated with people where you need
resources and all those are the kind of
skills that we really focus on so just
another we could talk a lot more about
these I'm just trying to give you a
quick
does it matter for adjacent versus
transformational for instance a PC to
laptop can be adjacent or
transformational yes it does the answer
is yes not that it matters the important
thing is to sort of see where you are on
that continuum whether you're doing core
adjacent or transformational all of that
is project-based work that is innovative
and so I think the important thing is
then to step back was going to be
different approaches you're going to
need if you're doing a project that's in
the R&D space out in transformational
you're going to have to have a much
lighter more agile like approach to that
versus something that's cool
it's just a slight tweaking and you've
done it before so those those would be
some of the types of things you need to
consider I get the idea to use PBW to
manage the innovation let me just back
up it's not managing it's doing the
innovation project-based work is how you
innovate you cannot innovate in your
firm without having projects that
produce what it is that the innovation
is now you ask a great question how do
we use PBW to come up with new ideas I
would suggest that that's really the
very beginning of and in Stanford we
talk a lot about design thinking and
approaches for coming up with creative
and innovative ways to do whatever it is
we are addressing and that's sort of
what I would call the front end a
project-based work what is it we're
trying to do is a new platform it is a
new laptop I'm looking at one right here
is it a new phone is it a new TV system
whatever that is and once that concept
idea comes up with then you need the
tools that we use a project-based work
income of the ones that we talked about
in the Stanford program to actually
execute that so it's a great great point
and I think those two together is where
the most innovative ideas come up you
need both of those it's not an either/or
what we're really trying to reinforce is
that the project-based work is
absolutely essential you can't just go
out and have a great brainstorming
session here's a cool idea you've got to
figure out how do I build it how to
deploy it how do I serve it those kind
of things so that's sort of a takeaway
there how does project-based work
integrate with the many project
methodologies available today
perfectly how's that for an answer
basically it's not any whatever
methodology are using whether you're
using a more agile type or more wor
fallers using classic project management
approaches that's not that's that
doesn't make any difference the
important thing is that all of those
result in innovation that's what with
that's the takeaway so it's not that
we're having to integrate that whatever
project management methodology you're
using what I want to lay on that is for
you to know that what you are doing is
innovating using that methodology so how
do you how do you pull that off
we have logic
I'm trying to go as fast as I can where
can we find a good framework for
structured PBW for employees who have
other routine job responsibilities in
addition to participate in in PBW that's
100 pound 800-pound gorilla of the
$500,000 questions
the if you think about structuring pvw
that I would say that's the type of
project or program methodology that
you're using in your organizations I
think the challenge as I understand this
is that what's happening is more and
more people have their day job and
they're having to run project based work
off the side of their desk or at night
and so the I think what organizations
need to be really clear this is
something that we talked about in the
classes I can't get into detail here but
this is really important that when
you're doing project-based work if you
also have operational responsibilities
it needs to be really clear how many of
those you have we see a lot of times
people running four five projects at the
same time and frankly something gets
lost in the shuffle when you do that and
it need to be really clear about focused
on what the responsibilities are when
you're working on that project base work
versus operations I know that's not a
good answer but that's all I can do it
you know we could probably have a whole
seminar just on that actually put that
over like just similar on that let's say
we got about four minutes left here
right right Robert yeah for five minutes
here okay and I'm going through these
post-its as fast as I can how do you
define PBW it seems like the projects
are part of ongoing business so it seems
like it would lead to incremental
changes how do you encourage truly
transformational changes can lead to
disruptive technologies okay
project-based work is what we would all
call again projects programs and the
portfolio's associated with funding them
think of your classic projects I'm just
using a project-based work as a
placeholder they are not part of the
ongoing business I'm going businesses
operations a project or a program is
being used to build a new product or a
revision to an existing product it's
being used to build a new facility or a
revision to an existing facility it
could be used to be doing a new process
or a revision to an existent process all
those are projects now the thing
that I would want to emphasize here it's
not right or wrong everything is not
transformational it's okay to have a
project that's working just on core
changes you've got to have that look at
just think of any today all of your
trying to intersect with a business
somewhere and they're going to do
something you say why don't they improve
that why do they do that that way
those are chord changes we want those
kind of innovations so that's why we use
the term that Scott Anthony has at
Harvard is that innovation is difference
with an impact obviously you want to
have a lot of those transformations but
a lot of people stay in business a long
time because they're very good at core
and adjacent innovation it's not
either/or either/or it's a both and so
there's probably something I should have
put in the big idea
I think both and okay yes how do you
explore address resistance you might get
from operations when working on PBW well
well well sometimes people have to do
both of those and I think one of the
things that I've noticed and others not
just myself is that we need to be really
open about involved in operations people
in project based work it's not them and
us and if you think about it why would
somebody in operations not want what
you're doing you're you're creating
something that they're going to be
running there's going to be an
improvement and if it's not it's right
this minute you look at all the projects
and project based work you're leading if
those are not improving how you're doing
business I would say time out go talk to
your sponsor and say why are we doing it
you're wasting your money you're wasting
your investors money if you're not going
to if you're not improving how you do
business and you should be doing the
project every project is about and so
the way you get over that resistance I
think it's better involvement during the
planning cycle having people in
operations involved from the very
beginning and once they get that I can't
you know if I'm in operations I can't
wait for the next shiny thing to come
along that's going to make me do this
better so that's that's just a thought
on that
if project-based work involves global
teams with huge language barriers we
actually have my course called leading
effective teams where we talk about this
I
the challenge of business right now is
leading globally distributed teams it
sounds cool and all that it's very hard
when you have people in five time zones
and the leaders I talked to it's like
you're always on 24 by 7 and so one of
the things there's a lot of best
practices in that that you can see if
the person had asked that can see me an
email I can send you you know some very
good references and that one of the key
things is making sure the team's really
fully supported and understood and
understands what is being done if at all
possible is great if this is a big
effort have everybody get together face
to face at the beginning everybody says
they can't do that this is one time as a
leader you need to push back and say
that's something else practice let's get
together
how can project-based work in a small
nonprofit organization limited resources
budget overwhelms paths hello it has to
work you may be small you may be a
non-profit but you're doing project so
it's even more important that you do
project based work well and you need to
be innovating just like a large thing so
you have limited resources budget and
overwhelms fast the way you handle that
is what you make sure you're doing work
that's in line with your goals and the
purpose of the organization secondly you
that work very well that's that's what I
notice it sounds try it at all but
that's how you have we handle that and
so I hear your pain and do that but best
practice is to make sure everybody is
aligned with the purpose of the
organization and hook them in the saddle
and and make sure they know why you're
doing the project okay we have one more
question and then we'll be closing out
here incidentally thank you I'm just
looking at these I know answer them
quickly you have my email feel free to
send me an email if you have other
questions you can follow us on LinkedIn
and other ways that Robert will mention
can you suggest some approaches to
change the focus with stakeholders to
the endgame instead of the project
becoming the entire focus obscured and
the real objective amen on that whoever
asked that question and one of the
things that basically think about
reaching re revisiting why in the heck
that we haven't meetings with our
stakeholders if you're having a meeting
where basically you're doing status and
everybody is reading the stuff
Sheetz shame on us if we do that those
meetings to be engaged internment about
how can we do make better decisions do
the work better and when you engage
those stakeholders is in that way
they're actually involved understanding
that the work that they are part of and
that you're leading is innovative and
that your company needs to be innovative
that's really what I want us to do is to
reframe really how we think about
project based work it's the innovation
engine of the company and I think with
that I'll turn it back over Robert
thanks a lot hope to see all of you on
campus at some time in the future
thank you John so this concludes our
question and answer portion for today
project-based work your key to
innovation as a reminder you may now
download a PDF of the slides by
selecting the print to a PDF option for
the file menu on the upper navigation
bar thank you again for joining us there
are still many questions in the queue
John will stay in the live meeting to
answer a few more questions by chat for
those of you who have had your questions
answered you may now disconnect thank
you so much
you